For this problem, imagine that your sitting on a swing set here that's 1 m off the ground,
and the swing itself is expanded 4 m below the top of the swing set here.
Now it turns out we can view the movement of you on the swing moving back and forth
as being the same as the movement of the pendulum back and forth.
For this problem, imagine that the maximum angle
you ever reach away from the vertical here is 45°.
When you swing back all the way and you run out of velocity,
you're at 45° away from the vertical line here.
And one time when your swinging forward, however, you decide to jump off the swing
when the swing makes an angle at the vertical of exactly 30°, and of course you end up going flying
and making a parabolic trajectory in the air before you finally land on the ground.
Now can you tell me how far away from the swing you land.
You should measure this distance from the point on the ground
to right below the point where you jumped off the swing.
Also, for this problem you should assume that you have a mass of 60 kg.
Put your answer here. Good luck!
Now just as a hint for solving this problem,
you're probably going to have to use conservation of energy, so keep that in mind.